i've got meerkats trying to get up my
trouser leg at the minute very luckily
inside the meerkat enclosure and the
reason they're quite so feisty for for
anything really to have a nibble on is
because it's feeding time and i'm with
simon garrett here who's very kindly let
us into the enclosure with an audience
of of people who've just um let's feed
them because i have a sock left in a
minute here we go there you go guys
and after 186 years
at the zoo is closing 90 million people
have visited the site here in clifton in
bristol
over nearly 200 years and these meerkats
will be going off to a different zoo in
uh november uh simon let's just have
while you're feeding them here let's
have a quick chat about what is going to
happen to all of the animals as the zoo
closes yeah well some of them are coming
with us to the nebraska zoo uh a
minority of them actually and others are
going after other zoos in this country
and across europe and across the world
as well so i mean zoos are very
collaborative we're always moving
animals around for our breeding program
so it's it's part of that it's just at
this time there's more going out to
other places than coming in at the
moment very quickly just tell us the
reason behind why the zoo is closing
because i know a lot of this land is
going to be made into housing isn't it
um yes um essentially we want to we're
running two sites they're wild place
projects as well and and that site is
ten times the size of this and we've
basically decided to concentrate on just
one site um which we want to develop so
by selling the clifton site we can
invest quite a large amount of money
into the new site and our role is all
about conservation so we have very
selective animals there which are all um
involved in conservation work related to
our field work around the world and the
other major thing which i'm i'm
particularly passionate about is getting
our visitors to be part of the solution
as well this is a major role of modern
zoos we can breed animals uh in zoos but
if there's no worth left in the wild
that's not going to help the same with
you know our field work and we can work
in a few places but if people can also
start choosing sustainable fish
sustainable timber sustainable palm oil
and that's the job of everybody in our
visitors so that that's the whole thing
about a modern zoo is engaging people
with being part of the solution and just
talking about modern zoos as i said over
there over 168 years 160 86 year history
we've been hearing how people used to
become be able to come to bristol zoo
here and ride on one of the elephants
rosie and thousands of people taking a
ride on i mean they really have changed
is there still a place though for zoos
in modern society a lot of people watch
it and they come and say we're caging
animals here we shouldn't have them at
all no the role is absolutely crucial
because i mean you can see the
engagement we've got from actually
meeting and seeing live animals here
close up um and engaging with with the
real work so i mean as an example you
know there'll be gorillas in our in a
new zoo and extra little guinea exhibits
um we're working with gorillas in the
wild we've got some photographs in
yesterday from our conservation team
of a group of gorillas on camera you
know wild gorillas and if we can engage
our visitors with that and give them to
be part of the solution that's the way
we get a sustainable planet for people
and for wildlife all right simon thanks
for chatting to us they've finished
their food which is why they've gone
back up my trouser leg
so we'll leave them in peace and i'll
try and get out in one piece the zoo
closes tomorrow that is the last day
that the public will be able to come and
enjoy these animals uh but for the time
being we'll cross back to you
no i think we should just stay on you
for a very long time done
we're going to call you the meerkat
whisperer in future
quite the image for a friday morning
thanks very much to everyone involved
thank you